here we will speak about the etiquette
of the holiday meal here are the
ingredients of the meal the flesh of a
dead bird
these are Brussels sprouts they are
nature's turd they taste like tiny turds
this is what you do with Brussels
sprouts
it is good etiquette this is stuffing it
is made of bread and vegetables it is
called stuffing because it was stuffed
into the anus of a dead bird delicious a
legume Billy has made a penis out of the
legume that is bad etiquette Billy
should be sent to his room by contrast
here Billy makes a penis on accident he
quickly fixes his mistake that is good
etiquette now you don't have to go to
your room Billy here are cranberries and
a mash of potato what is Billy hidden
under his mash look it's the cranberry
he's being silly look at the nice way
that Billy has arranged his food on the
plate
now he has arranged it by colors he is
being creative look Billy is not very
hungry now and he still makes a nice
plate look at the tiny bites he has made
now he has made a food pyramid Billy has
no friends he has separated his food he
is an obsessive maybe he writes computer
programs Billy is acting like an idiot
he is playing with his food he has made
a bear drawing on his plate Billy needs
therapy he has made a nice drawing Billy
doesn't need therapy now here is the
correct way of using your eating utensil
this is the wrong way this is bad
etiquette Billy makes a divot in his
mesh for his gravy he is sexually
frustrated Billy went on a date look at
how he applies his gravy now now Billy
is addicted to pornography he doesn't
like the salad it reminds him of death
now it's time for pie Billy takes a
small piece how much is left
how much pie is left here is a graph may
I have some whipped please Billy is
still addicted to pornography he is
finished now and he sees things on his
messy plate Billy sees the devil now he
sees something different he is unusual
no the meal is now done and Billy says
Happy Holidays